well i mean it just means that you can't
keep a good dream down
whoopi goldberg is one of only a handful
of artists to live out the entertainment
dream
and he got my first guest tonight is an
egot winner the emmy the grammy the
oscar and the tony
here's how whoopi earned her way into
this exclusive club of award winners
so you trying to eager
[Music]
all these awards i got i got for
projects i believe time
wait is that a daytime image it still
counts
girls gotta eat that emmy was actually
the award that completed whoopi's egot
the statue came in 2002 for hosting the
tv special beyond tara the extraordinary
life of hattie mcdaniel
an in-depth look at the career and civil
rights work of the groundbreaking
actress
this is my second at me whoopi later
received several
other emmy nominations including another
win in 2009 for co-hosting the view
it's nice but it's a little it's a
little i don't know i'm sweating
in 1986 whoopi's egot journey was
jump started by the grammy award
she won best comedy album for the
original recording from her breakout
broadway
show i'm real glad i'm real glad
you know it's very bizarre this i wasn't
paying any attention to because it would
never enter into our minds
at all you know i thought i made this
regular the show nobody's gonna
and people listen to excuse me people
listen to it
you know and and what a surprise my
daughter had to say
get up get up they are calling
your name get up it's like what
oh oh oh okay get us together think of
something witty you know
get up the stairs you endanger girl
jump to 1990 and whoopi's movie star
making performance in one of the year's
biggest blockbusters ghost i had
i had a great time you know i didn't
have to be over emotional or mushy or
any of that stuff i didn't have to worry
about
you know what the message was or any of
that all
all i was there to do was have some fun
and hey sometimes a fun gig will lead to
getting the o
in your egot the following year whoopi
won the oscar for best supporting
actress
i used to watch movies when i was a kid
i mean that's what
that's where my idea of the world came
from and those were people that i
thought that i could be around those
were people that i
sort of understood and part of
of doing that part of watching movies
and stuff
is is the oscars and so every year since
i was like
six i'd have something to say you know
and so now
i got up there and i i couldn't remember
anything and i
i wanted it because i did good work fast
forward to where we began
2002. it feels right
you know feels right i'm particularly
happy to be here representing my show
which has a very good chance of winning
the tony which i'm very excited about
whoopi won a tony award for producing
that year's hit
show thoroughly modern millie and then
they said thoroughly modern miller and
the cast was standing backstage
and i was pushing him out to go on stage
and one of them turned around and said
come on
it's like oh yeah okay so
it's kind of great i had an idea and
several other people had an idea and
then we met at the mock hotel
the next thing you know we all got
tony's
now whoopi's remarkable one-of-a-kind
career can't just be defined by this
real-life
infinity gauntlet of trophies whoopi's
also been celebrated with
two golden globes a bafta award the glad
media awards
vanguard award a star on the walk of
fame
handprints at grauman's chinese theater
plenty of kids choice awards
the mark twain prize for american humor
a handful of people's choice awards
and last but not least she's also an
honorary harlem globetrotter
i don't think i've been that stunned in
a long time and we'll toss in one more
honor for this icon
how about most outstanding post award
show celebration plans
i'm going home babe i'm going home
taking my behind home i was cute i did
my thing
i'm done